problema número 106 la proporción actual
de estudiantes con respecto a profesores
en cierta escuela es de 31 si los
alumnos inscritos se incrementan en 50 y
el número de profesores se incrementa en
5 la nueva proporción será 25 a 1 cuál
es el número actual de profesores vamos
a verlo anotemos los datos que nos dan
nos dicen que la proporción es de 30 a 1
de estudiantes con respecto a profesores
estudiantes con respecto a profesores
tienen una proporción de 30 a 1 que el
número de profesores se incrementa en 5
y el número de alumnos inscritos se
incrementa en 50 por lo que tenemos que
los estudiantes se incrementa en 50 y
los profesores se incrementan en 5 ahora
nos dicen que esta nueva proporción es
igual a 25 a 1 vamos a simplificar esto
esto entre p o estudiantes entre
profesores igual a 30 entre 1 eso es lo
mismo que tener igual a 30
/ p es igual a 30 vamos a despejar los
estudiantes los estudiantes es igual a
30 por p por los profesores y ahora
sustituyamos esto en esta otra ecuación
ya que nos interesa conocer p cada que
veamos una vez vamos a sustituir
esto nos quedan 30 p más 50 entre p más
5 igual a 25 entre 1 que es lo mismo que
25 igual a 25 multiplicamos todo por 5
nos va a quedar 30 p más 50 igual a 25
por p 25 p más 25 por 5 que es igual a
125 125 ahora restemos 25 p en ambos
lados aquí restamos 25 p aquí también
este se va - 25 p más 30 p va a ser
igual a 5 p más 50 igual a 125 ahora
restemos 50 en ambos lados y nos va a
quedar 5 p igual a 125 menos 52 que las
75 y ahora dividimos todo entre 5 p es
igual a 75 entre 5 que es igual a 15 y
esta es nuestra opción
siguiente problema número 107 cuál es el
entero más pequeño n para el cual se
cumple la desigualdad 25 n mayor que 5 a
la 12
siempre que vean una desigualdad en
donde la variable se encuentra como
exponente y además las bases son
diferentes lo primero que deben de
pensar es cómo poner los elementos en la
misma base aquí es bastante obvio porque
5 x 5 da 25 esto lo podemos poner como 5
al cuadrado elevado a la n es mayor que
5 a la 2 esto lo podemos expresar como 5
elevado a 2 por n mayor a 5 elevado a la
12 y esto va a ser verdadero cuando los
exponentes ya que la base es la misma
cuando 2 n sea mayor que 12 dividimos a
ambos lados entre 2 nos va a quedar que
n es mayor que 6 cuál es el entero más
pequeño para que se cumpla que n sea
mayor que 6 cómo
desigualdad es mayor no igual de las
opciones que tenemos nuestra opción es
el número 7 que es la opción b el número
7 cumple con esto siguiente problema
problema número 108 si xy son números
primos diferentes ambos mayores que dos
cuales de las siguientes opciones es
verdadera más bienes son verdaderas son
verdaderas aquí un pequeño error citó
pero continuemos veamos x más es
diferente de 91 hay algún par de números
primos diferentes y mayores a 2 que al
sumarse de 91 sabemos que todos los
números primos son impares 2 es el único
número primo par así que si tenemos un
impar
más otro impar que nos va a dar
bueno un empate lo podemos también
expresar como dos por una variable la
llevamos acá más un uno y así tenemos un
impar supongamos que este es x aunque
aquí estoy indicando que es un impar no
necesariamente que es un número primo
pero todos los números primos mayores a
dos son impares así que aquí se cumple
esto ahora digamos que ya que es otro
impar va a ser 2 por otra variable
llamémosla m + 1 y ahora hagamos la suma
de estos dos que nos va a dar va a ser 2
k más 12 m que puedo ponerlo como dos
por cada más m
más uno más uno más dos
esto es un par así que cuando se suman
doce impares nos va a dar como resultado
un número par si sumamos dos números
primos mayores a dos el resultado no
puede ser un número impar sino uno par
así que no puede ser igual al 91 esta
primera opción es verdadera veamos la
siguiente x menos espacio
ya tenemos expresado estos números como
impares vamos a hacer la resta en lugar
de la suma qué pasa si yo en lugar de
sumar los los restos ahora voy a tener
dos por cada menos m y 1 menos 10 queda
esto dos porque a menos m este 2 por lo
que esté multiplicando aquí lo que sea
esto nos va a dar un número par así que
la resta x menos spad aunque este número
sea negativo pero va a seguir siendo par
entonces esta también se cumple veamos
la siguiente x entre y no es entero
sabemos que x es primo es decir que solo
tiene dos factores sólo puede ser
divisible entre uno y sí mismo lo mismo
pasa con ya si esto fuera cierto y el
resultado de esta división fuera un
entero esto quiere decir que ya es un
factor d
pero como son primos esto no se cumple
por lo que la opción 3x / no es un
entero esto también es cierto y de las
opciones la que indica que las tres son
verdaderas es la del inciso y esta es
nuestra respuesta siguiente problema
problema número 109 todos los siguientes
tienen el mismo valor
excepto vamos a hacer estas operaciones
rápidamente uno más dos es tres más 13
64 es 10 más 5 es 15 15 entre 13 es
igual a 5 ok veamos el siguiente un
tercio por 12 345 un tercio por 5 es
igual a 5 tercios y ahora sumamos un
tercio más otro tercio son dos tercios
aquí son tres tercios aquí cuatro
tercios aquí cinco tercios esto es igual
a cinco tercios también y de estas
respuestas la que vemos que es diferente
es la opción
es diferente a las demás y con esto
terminamos el vídeo de hoy